so you can see stages wanted to are
already there this is the this is one
you will receive sort of you know with
this column of my hand side actually
filled out money grab a sheet and so
you'll get your original back there and
your prototyping mark and then you have
added all of the implementation stage
and what marks you get rewarded for that
okay so first let's have a look at the
front of life now just to reiterate what
I said last week the final product is
due on Thursday right let's do this term
as opposed to the project report which
is due later
now before I talk about any of the
actual elements please note that the
implementation stage as a whole is sixty
five months right
thirty-three of those months are in the
product thirty-two are in the report
okay now that division is is very
intentional I hope you get that I'm
trying to demonstrate something here
it's kind of like it mats you know how
they say you're working is really
important it's sort of something we have
to beat out of you from primary school
that you know primary school maths is
kind of just get the answer and that's
the important thing are you right or
you're wrong
okay but in maths in high school we're
about can you demonstrate the understand
how you got there had the person is
really important and that's why the
project report is do is worth so much
okay so they start to talk about some of
the elements under the final product
demonstrate original and creative use of
appropriate software okay what does that
mean I try to put original creative
they're kind of sitting rooms but people
get different connotations with them
what am I trying to avoid in any kind of
software that you use if you use it in a
basic sort of way you can get something
that's sort of workable out of it
so example in PowerPoint or in Google
Docs that kind of thing or insights for
that matter there's a whole bunch of
preset templates that you can use which
will you know produce something that's
kind of workable it looks semi
attractive and will give you sort of a
professional look in some ways because
they were designed by professionals
right but that doesn't really
demonstrate creative use of the software
you're it's not your creativity it's
someone else's right and you're just
using the template so as an example what
I'm looking for is if you created a
website which is most of you but not all
of you I'm looking for you to go past
what was just the the standard forms
that we give it to you have you adapted
a little bit have you
not around them to see how it could fit
for your purposes rather than just gave
taken what was stock standard and run
with that okay in the same way I'm
looking for you to explore all the
different kinds of options and all the
different things that you could tweak
and adjust in if you're looking at you
know video editing software right there
are a basic effects really standard ones
which are easy to apply but there will
be what did you take more effort and
which are trickier to use which will be
really helpful for your project so have
you pursued those kinds of settings and
features in the software that you're
using
that's what original a creative use
means okay are you pushing the software
to its limits or are you just using sort
of the basic functions something which
which anyone could walk off the street
and do second dot point the system
employs all media types substantially
okay hopefully that doesn't be as much
information all I'm looking for is okay
our all of the multimedia attacks we've
studied in the course are they
represented in your system and
importantly are they represented
substantially okay so the classic
example where people fall down on this
actually is to text and audio text and
audio okay text you might think oh
there's always going to be text in there
right but sometimes people use text in a
way which is kind of like I've just
dumped all this text here and I haven't
thought about whether it's actually
gonna be you sort of the project or not
or appropriate right the same thing
happens to audio but in Reverse people
kind of had it man what are your
productions really hard I don't know how
to make it fit with my project and so
it's sort of there as a in a token way
but not substantially okay so I've
marked many major projects in the past
well the sole containment of audio in
the whole project is just so background
music on the website okay dance nothing
wrong with background music for the
website okay well is it just like a
30-second
audio clip which actually doesn't add
very much to your project if I removed
it would your project suffer
particularly where people sense
something different about the system
would it have an effect on how they read
the story and that kind of thing
well maybe not okay so you really need
to think carefully about you guys
actually have it way better than the
first people who I gave this project to
you you guys all have audio software and
hardware in your pockets on your phones
and your laptops and you have a lot of
access to so play around with that and
not just put on like an audio track with
very very little actual adjustment so
when it says substantial that means have
you actually given some thought to how
you're going to put this in and is it
there in a real way if I took it away
would you lose something out of the
project okay all right thirdly showcases
unique strengths of each media type okay
this is related to the previous one
right but are you using text where text
should be used are using video where it
should be used or I just kind of use a
video because I wanted to lump
everything together and the main example
I just showed you at the beginning was a
video okay that's not necessarily gonna
be a helpful use of the media type and
this is six marks right so what I'm
looking for you to do is okay numbers
appear here for a reason one of the
reasons why I gave you a mystery as a
the kind of system and you were going to
create is because it actually opens up
all kinds of different ways to use media
types in unusual ways and one of the
examples was internet story right he
uses a numerical data type as a as a
code right which is actually it totally
fits with the the genre that you're
using right it's not like I put numbers
here because the marking rubric said I
have to put numbers okay he actually
fits with the project okay showcases
unique strengths so think carefully as
well about for instance some of you have
put captions onto your videos or you
said you want to put captions on your
videos now again it's nothing wrong with
captions but are you putting captions in
because your audio is not good not
because the captions are actually this
is the best way to convey
your information okay are you putting
captions because the video is not clear
maybe you should make the video clearer
rather than using a media type for which
it's not really student okay sometimes
you put captions into a movie because it
conveys something really important okay
for years since I mean I know it's a
trivial example but if you got
characters in a scene and they're
speaking another language then you don't
want other characters to know but you
want the audience to know that's an
appropriate use of subtitles right but
just putting subtitles in because your
act up or you is just talking too fast
right that's that's not a good use of
the media time that's actually it's sort
of like a crutch I admitted I didn't do
a very good job so I sort of used
multimedia one of the types to cover
that weakness okay that's not playing to
the strengths all right before I go on
are there any questions about those
first three points right now before
suitable balance between breadth of
content and level of detail in other
words the scope of the final product
represents an appropriate achievement
given the development limit limitations
okay so I hope you can see there's a
contrast there between breadth and depth
right so for instance if you made like a
30 second film and that was the whole
thing right but it was a really good 30
seconds okay
that would still be kind of probably not
an appropriate achievement given the
limitations that you were given namely
you were given weeks and weeks and weeks
to produce a project and 30 seconds even
though it may have put a lot of time
into those 30 seconds it's not gonna be
a substantial product at the other end
in the same way if you have like a
really more like a 25 minute fear but
it's pretty rubbish and the camera
angles are terrible and you've you
haven't you've seen some scenes they're
not very good but you haven't reshot
them to sort of improve the quality of
it then again that's not a bounces we
breadth and depth right so I'm
essentially looking to see have you used
your time effectively okay being that
the parameters of the project were you
could do anything you liked
have you chosen something
that fits what you were required to what
time you actually had to work with the
project okay
content effectively conveys a story with
mystery elements okay now I had to put
this in it's only one element out of six
for the final product okay but I am
looking for you to tell a story well
right for it to be actually a compelling
mystery now if the mystery sucks you you
won't get full marks for that but it's
not can you see it's not gonna
compromise your entire project it's only
five bucks out of 33 for the final
product and most of you from what I've
seen the prototypes you actually have
quite interesting stories and slightly
creepy stories for some of you very
creepy stories but I'm looking for you
to actually okay I've used music because
here it's really effective and producing
a mood in the system or I've put thought
into this story and when you've finished
it at the end you're like ah I want to
go back and do this again because it's
it's quite compelling and quite
interesting right and does it
effectively convey that right so if you
use techniques like like voiceovers like
camera angles all that kind of thing
when people watch it are they gonna feel
like yes this is a mystery and lastly
for the final product it exhibits
multiple levels of refinement that
reflect the spa development approach
okay so we've been studying this to
death right but despite the whole point
of the spider venom approach is that the
quality of the whole product improves
incrementally as time passes right that
you don't have okay when I was 50%
through the way the project I had the
first five minutes of my 10-minute film
filmed and I hadn't touched the last
five minutes the idea is I have all 10
minutes they're not very good but once I
put them all together I could see how
they fit and I can show it to people and
ask for some feedback as opposed to if I
just had the first by a bit of people
watch it they'll be like well my
feedback is it's not finished right so
I'm gonna be looking for things like
okay is the audio of a decent quality
are the links are pointing to the right
places are there spelling errors you
know I mean apart from intentional ones
because you know it's
maybe that's part of your clues for your
project okay I'm gonna be looking for
things like that images are they are
they well chosen are they arranged in a
helpful way are they just the first ones
if I search for you know for instance if
part of your puzzle sorry part of your
project has to do with puzzles right
like Leo's is the titles of his jigsaw
right and suppose he has pictures of
puzzles when I go a Google image search
and I put in puzzle is it just gonna be
the first 10 pictures on the page okay
that's not multiple levels of refinement
you have enough time you can go take
your own pictures right you could go
ahead go back and reshoot scenes because
the first time you did them the lighting
was quite poor or the audio wasn't very
good all those kinds of things right
that's what having a project of this
link and forcing you to do a prototype
early on and then getting your final
product out of you that's the point
behind it okay so I'm looking for it to
be refined for it to be yeah I saw this
and I've improved upon it as opposed to
you know what usually happens when you
submit something like a project and then
you get it back you're like wow I can't
believe I made these basic errors
because that's what happens when you're
down to the wire and you've you know
you've finished the last scene you know
at 8:45 in the morning before you head
to head it in okay so we're trying to
avoid that we're trying to make sure
every element of the project is refined